Speaker 1: All right.
Let's discuss some of the goings on of the
last 24 hours as Joe Biden has continued to
not really make a big deal out of himself
one way or the other, but just kind of like
be a very calm presence as president of the
United States, doing some things that I like.
And then certainly there are things I would
like Joe Biden to do that he has not done,
but it's just sort of been very normal feeling.
The failed former president Donald Trump has
been doing interview after appearance after
declaration, showing truly how sick he is
at this point in time.
And the first example of this that I want
to look at is an interview that Donald Trump
gave yesterday to Newsmax.
These interviews are these would make North
Korean news anchors blush.
These would make Russian propagandists say,
oh, no, this is even too much for me.
Here is a statement.
Trump is completely scrambled.
His brain is completely scrambled.
We're in the same 50 seconds.
He says that he built the wall, but that he
would have built the wall if he had only had
three more weeks.
And also quite telling that increasingly Trump
is not doing interviews with Fox News, he's
doing them with Newsmax.
And that's all part of the sort of downfall
of Trump.
And we'll talk more about the data behind
that claim in a moment.
Speaker 2: Mr. President, you know, another
issue that the Biden administration has really
completely messed up the border.
Speaker 1: It's just totally messed up, guys.
Speaker 2: Now, what you have is Governor
Ron DeSantis is taking offensive action.
He's taking some of the immigrants and putting
them in Martha's Vineyard.
Speaker 1: What is really an incredibly important
thing that DeSantis did.
Speaker 3: I think that the border is such
a disappointment because we had the safest
border, we had the best border in the history
of our country.
We built the wall.
And then I built additions to the wall, which
could have been finished in three weeks.
Speaker 1: I built he built the wall.
Now, remember, the wall was defined as a wall
across the entire border.
He says, We built the wall and then we could
have finished it within three weeks.
Wait, so did you build it or did you not?
Speaker 3: The majority of it and everything
we said we were going to get done.
And then they came to me and they wanted to
know we could do an extra 150 to 200 mile.
Speaker 1: Yeah, they came to me with tears
in their eyes and they said, Sir, we need
another 100 miles.
Now, listen, the promise that Trump made was
a wall across the entire southern border by
the end of his first term.
By different accounts, something like 90 to
100 and something miles were added.
And of course, it's a wall that could be defeated
with about $100 worth of parts from a Home
Depot or a hardware store.
Donald Trump then said that the video of the
search warrant being executed at Mar a Lago
looks like a military coup, which is interesting
language from the guy who tried to execute
a coup president.
Speaker 2: We keep hearing about video recordings
at Mar a Lago that would have captured the
raid.
Have you had conversations about releasing
that footage, right?
Speaker 3: Yes, we have.
And they would rather have me not do it because
of the safety of the FBI agents that swarmed
the place.
Speaker 1: Right.
Trump's really concerned with keeping the
FBI agents safe.
Speaker 3: I don't think they wanted to swarm
in.
If you want to know the truth, I have a great
relationship with people in the in the FBI.
But they didn't.
And we are very precise.
And, you know, it's not a pretty picture either.
It looks like a military coup.
It's not a pretty picture.
You know, they didn't want they wanted to
put the safety of the people that are on the
footage.
It's very clear.
And for the safety of the people that are
in the footage, they would.
They've asked us not to not to put it out.
Speaker 1: So, you know, it's very interesting.
Speaker 2: That.
Speaker 1: Reality doesn't have any bearing
anymore to the extent that it ever did right
anymore.
When these right wingers talk about things
in the real world for a very long time, the
January six riot coup insurrection attempt.
Call it what you want.
It was peaceful and it was beautiful and it
was a great thing.
And then all of a sudden it was well, no,
it was violent, but it was Antifa and then
it was.
Well, though it's a it doesn't really matter.
It's just whatever they can say at the time
and now something that was very peaceful.
The FBI shows up with a signed search warrant.
FBI director signed off on it.
Attorney General Merrick Garland signed off
on it.
Judge signed off on that.
Now is a violent military coup.
And Trump kind of continued playing this up
when he talked about how violated Melania
felt when the FBI ruffled through her dresses
and maybe other things of hers as well.
Speaker 2: I'm wondering how Melania felt
about the raid.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: By the way, a really hard hitting
question from I believe this is Rick Grenell,
who's like a former Trump staffer doing the
interview.
I guess he works for Newsmax now, who knows?
Really incisive German.
How did Melania feel about what happened?
Speaker 3: Well, she felt very violated, right?
This is a terrible thing.
They're going.
Speaker 1: To anyway.
Trump would know about women feeling violated
right.
Speaker 3: To a closet.
They go through addresses and who knows what
else.
And it wasn't left the away it it's.
Speaker 1: Her dresses, by the way.
They didn't go through her scarves.
They didn't go through her blouses.
But those dresses, they were right up in there.
Speaker 3: Found it.
Okay.
I didn't exactly.
I didn't I didn't walk into mine and say,
oh, this is exactly so nice.
The way they put it back.
I think it's a disgrace that a thing like
this could happen.
Yeah.
And again, we didn't do anything wrong.
I didn't do anything wrong.
There was nothing done wrong.
You take a look at the Presidential Records
Act.
That's what you have to go by.
Yes.
Speaker 1: He's sure he didn't do anything
wrong.
And maybe it's because of something related
to the Presidential Records Act.
Remember this?
This really is a big deal for the FBI and
Justice Department to take this step.
You know, that they were really confident
that they knew exactly what they were looking
for.
They knew exactly what Trump was supposed
to have turned over and that they were crossing
every eye and dotting every t as Sean HANNITY
said, this this narrative just doesn't it's
not believable.
Speaker 3: I mean, that's what I'm told.
And you sit, you negotiate, you try working
it out.
And if you don't, I guess there's a procedure
if you can't work it out.
Yes.
And it's you know, they're making they're
trying to make such a big deal because what
they want to do is politicize every.
Speaker 1: Yeah, of course, it doesn't appear
that that's the case.
It appears as though the FBI gave Donald Trump
a lot of time to return the things that he
took.
And they had reason to believe he hadn't returned
it and they were 100% correct.
Lastly, here, is Trump still complaining about
the FBI being in his bedroom?
Speaker 3: You have that happened.
And then they do a raid on the house of a
former president who is very popular.
I mean, I did get more votes than any sitting
president in history.
Right.
Any president even came close.
Speaker 1: It's it's almost like he's saying
you can't raid a popular former president.
You should only be able to raid an unpopular
one.
Speaker 3: And they did a raid on my house.
And it's, you know, not the same.
You walk in and you say, these people are
in here and in your bedroom and they weren't.
Speaker 2: In Baron's rubble and rule, audience
rule.
Speaker 3: So I mean, when you think how terrible
it is, it's terrible.
Speaker 1: It's just absolutely terrible.
And then absolute last clip, during this very
same deranged and sick interview, Trump's
delusions about his own power continue.
He says if he were still the president right
now, he would meet with Putin and he would
get that invasion of Ukraine ended.
Speaker 2: Mr. President, it's Rob Finnerty.
I don't think it could be overstated.
Inflation was 1.4% on your last day in office.
Gas was 239 a gallon.
Quite a difference 20 months later.
Speaking of Russia, Vladimir Putin wanted
to showcase Russian strength in Ukraine when
he invaded in February.
Mr. President, the opposite is happening.
That is clear.
If you were in the Oval Office today, how
would you do more to address directly with
Vladimir Putin to try to get him to stop this
war?
Speaker 3: Well, I talk to him.
I'd meet with him.
I mean, there's no communication with him,
with Biden.
Obviously, there's not a lot of a lot of communication
between Biden and these leaders.
These leaders, they're pretty brutal.
And they are people that you have to know
how to deal with.
And we dealt with them well with China.
We took in hundreds of billions of dollars
of tariffs.
Speaker 1: Now, remember that China doesn't
pay the tariffs.
American companies do.
What's really funny about that is that when
Hillary Clinton said this, really, it wasn't
a great thing that Hillary said.
When Hillary said, you know, I went to Wall
Street and I told them, cut it out.
And everybody laughed at her because it's
so silly.
Oh, you told Wall Street to cut it out.
I'm sure right away they're going to cut it
out.
Trump is basically saying the same thing here.
He's saying, listen, I would have met with
Putin.
I would have told them, stop it, just stop
it.
That's it.
It's pathetic.
And increasingly, Trump's visibility is coming
on fringe networks like Newsmax.
Not that Fox News isn't Fringe, but it's at
least in terms of cable subscriptions, more
mainstream.
But Trump increasingly relegated to more bizarre
interviews on smaller and smaller platforms.